making the start will be marco gonzalez
ninth start of the season the record of
one and four era of 5.44
not overpowering by any stretch he's
going to mix up his pitches he's going
to mix up his locations and his command
has to be very good for him to have
success as you can see 10 home runs
allowed in his 41 and the third inning
so that has been an issue for him and
look for the race to be patient and
tried to attack those mistakes out over
the plate
swing and a miss for strike three so
gonzalez comes back g-man choi on at
first base with one out swinging a
ground ball up the middle crawford to
his left little pop toss over to moore
at second for one the relay to first and
it's in time for the double play six
four three they get joy at second and
double up for rosa reign over at first
base shane mcclanahan making his tent
start of the season looking to improve
on these numbers
talked about him in the open duane the
first six very good last three not so
much swung on and grounded right to
third backhanded by yandi off balance
throw in the dirt nice pick by
g monchoy at the other end and that's
out number one here in the bottom of the
first is that a pretty play to get the
day started diaz was shallow
and did the the best thing he could do
field it and get rid of it as fast as he
could the throw was online didn't have
enough on it but on the clean bounce
troy with a fantastic backhand stabbing
scoop tampa bay rays so as we go to the
bottom of the third are still without a
run but for that matter so is seattle
and shane mcclanahan hoping to keep it
that way he swings and hits a rocket out
to left center field luis terrence
first pitch bottom of the third going
yard putting the mariners in front one
nothing
well we know luis had his struggles
offensively and also behind the plate to
begin the season but
he tees off on a
elevated
mile an hour offering from mcclanahan
and drives it out 412 feet to the pen
hoist in no time
one on for the raise mariners lead one
nothing top of the fourth thinning tying
around the board here's g man choi swung
out on a fly ball into center feeling
deep fraley going back to the warning
track he's there leaps up and he makes
the catch at the top of the wall his hat
comes flying off he gets to throw in
it's cut off by crawford back to first
base goes margot
and what a catch by jake fraley running
out of room in a hurry slammed into the
wall and straight away center field at
the top of the fence
and he takes away a home run from g-man
joy what a play
by jake fraley
his glasses went flying off his head his
cap went one way he went the other nine
run at second the go ahead run out at
first base one nothing mariner's lead
and that'll bring up austin meadows
swung on one hopper to first take it by
france down to second for one crawford's
relay back to france three six three
double play and marco gonzalez gets out
of the inning what a play by france he
got to it on the short hop half step to
his left fire down to jp they get a rosa
reign at second they double up meadows
at first base
the infield in all the way let's see
what manuel can do here he has struck
out and he has walked he's been one of
the better hitters for the race in these
situations for most of the season fargo
shoots it toward the alley and right
center field wendell scores margot's got
to get an extra base on this one the
game is tied and margot is in scoring
position the infield in there's a lot of
room and he got it over the infield and
then bisected fraley and bowers in right
center
i thought it might go for a triple but
he hit it hard where it got to the wall
pretty fast an rbi double by margaux
three hits one run one walk seven
strikeouts the best start in a while two
going in the sixth one to one our score
and that'll bring kyle seeger to the
plate sliders swinging and missed strike
three and a pump of the fish
for shane mcclanahan is for the first
time in his big league career
he gets through six innings here here is
zanino
marco working with the go ahead run
behind him at second base with his
second straight
a inning base hit and one hops the wall
wow will score the go ahead run it's two
to one raise on back to back doubles
from lau enzenino
well that was a bullet no chance for
shed long
to be able to gather that one
went down and almost one hand fretted it
out toward left field hooked it
and was able to get it by long and then
one hop over the wall to the raised boat
bender just to the left of the raised
boat fan and that's probably going to do
it
for gonzalez it looks like they're going
to come out and get him
and they'll go to the bullpen well now
it's time to close it out ryan thompson
going to come out of that bullpen for
the 32nd time
33 strikeouts
30 in the third innings giving up just
the two home runs
nothing in the last nine games i'll tell
you he's been really good you start to
think about that fastball good velocity
running it up in the zone then he's got
the different types of breaking balls
that he will come at these hitters with
he's got a one run lead into the home
seventh inning france moore bowers due
up swing and this is crushed out towards
left center field did he get all of it
did he get it all it's gone yes he did
game time solo home run time france this
game is even at two
that's the way to extend your hitting
straight to nine games
three home runs over his last nine ball
games ty france out to the pen there in
left center field
and right now they're starting to come
in bunches for ties a big strong kid
gets a breaking ball
middle in turns on it gets it out to
left center brandon is the go ahead run
at first base you know mike zenino who
doubled him home last time up comes up
to the plate here strike three called
and that will retire the side second
rider strikes out the side here with the
top of the ninth inning the americans
are trying to sweep the rays in four
games highlighted by what would be their
third walkoff win of the series swing
out to right field this is on its way
back and it's gone
walk off home run you did it chad long
jr
it's a walk walk-off slam
what a moment
the mariners can't do anything but walk
off the rays
they do it for the third time and sweep
aside tampa bay in four
what a storybook finish again and again
and again shed long's first home run of
the season
is a walk-off grand slam
what a finish and a sweep of the four
game set against one of the best teams
in the american league and look at that
celebration out there at home plate they
were ready for shed long to get to the
plate and a standing ovation by the
father's day crowd